[Musique]
un mouvement qui est super pour pouvoir
faire tout seul à la maison c'est les
baies reprises les deux reprises voici
ce que c'est clément va nous montrer
alors c'est je me pose au sol et je
remonte
voilà je descends je pose les mains au
sol et je retiens une version plus
simple quand on a un petit peu moins
l'habitude c'est je descend
tranquillement et un pied après l'autre
je recule je ramène les pieds et je me
redresse cet exercice il est génial pour
pouvoir travailler plein de choses on a
le gainage qui travaillent on a tout les
jambes qui travaillent le fait de
remonter et redescendre
on a également en fait tous les muscles
travaillent tous les muscles sont
sollicités
ce qui fait que ça amène énormément ça
brûle énormément de callot et c'est le
mouvement qui vaut le plus de calories
parmi tous les mouvements sportifs et
alors notre conseil c'est de pouvoir le
faire par exemple une série de dix 10
bord pis comme ça et on le fait 5 séries
comme ça et un jour sur deux et c'est un
excellent moyen pour éliminer un petit
peu les surplus des faits
[Musique]
pour une détaxe plutôt détente
je peux vous proposer une posture de
yoga simplement sa sauce allongé
tranquillement sur le dos posez les bras
bien ouverts sur les côtés placez une
jambe par dessus l'autre et laisser
tomber les jambes sur le côté expiré au
maximum pour pouvoir vous détendre dans
la posture et revenaient tranquillement
[Musique]
au niveau nutrition pour la détox après
les fêtes la première chose à faire
c'est diminuer les glucides les glucides
c'est quoi c'est le pain et les pâtes et
les viennoiseries c'est tout ce qui à
base de céréales
donc ça on élimine si on veut par contre
continue à faire des petits apéro on
peut quand même prendre des cacahuètes
mais en revanche on les prend nature ni
sa les négriers
ça c'est la première chose et si on a
encore une petite nostalgie du chocolat
on prend un petit peu de chocolat mais
c'est uniquement du noir 85 % minimum